Caption: all righty
Caption: hi
Caption: i'm haley
Caption: and i am super excited to be here today
Caption: um so thank you for deciding to join me
Caption: thank you for voting my talk into ddd as
Caption: well i guess
Caption: um before i get too excited and too
Caption: carried away i just want to give a quick
Caption: shout out to all the amazing sponsors of
Caption: ddd so thank you so much for sponsoring
Caption: this conference i'm really excited to be
Caption: part of it this year
Caption: and yeah thank you for joining me so
Caption: hello my name is haley
Caption: feel free to check me to follow on
Caption: twitter i tweet a lot about coding fails
Caption: my dog
Caption: uh and mental health so if you're
Caption: interested in any of those things um
Caption: please say hi to me on twitter i'd love
Caption: to chat with you
Caption: um outside of twitter i'm the tech lead
Caption: for she codes so she codes is a social
Caption: enterprise that's under the child it's a
Caption: child of space cubed which is a
Caption: co-working space here in the city
Caption: and our role at shecodes is to try and
Caption: increase the number of women in tech so
Caption: we have a very lofty goal of trying to
Caption: inspire 100 000 women into tech by 2025
Caption: which is
Caption: sneaking up on us very very quickly um
Caption: but it's something that we're really
Caption: excited about so my job at shecodes is
Caption: the tech lead it's technically not in a
Caption: typical sense so i don't lead a team of
Caption: developers but rather i lead a small
Caption: army of mentors
Caption: that we are training to then teach other
Caption: people how to get into tech so we train
Caption: mentors who are developers in the
Caption: community here to so that they can be
Caption: better mentors for budding developers or
Caption: junior developers
Caption: so that's part of my job i also write a
Caption: bunch of educational content about
Caption: computer science and programming so i'm
Caption: the one who puts together most of our
Caption: workshops and i teach most of our
Caption: workshops
Caption: and generally i just love computer
Caption: science and education and all things
Caption: around that so i've been doing this for
Caption: basically my whole career i've been
Caption: either in tech or in uh education but
Caption: almost always i'm in a cross section
Caption: between the two
Caption: um because whenever i pick one i end up
Caption: missing the other so i've just kind of
Caption: landed in the middle
Caption: so
Caption: hopefully it's uh coming across by now
Caption: um how much i love education and tech
Caption: and computer science and i hope you're
Caption: already super intrigued by what's going
Caption: on in front of me because we're going to
Caption: do a bit of everything today
Caption: so that leads me here so why am i giving
Caption: a talk about the computer science uh
Caption: behind color um there are a few reasons
Caption: so
Caption: the most superficial is just i'm such a
Caption: nerd about this stuff i just find this
Caption: really really fascinating um and i
Caption: figured it was interesting so surely
Caption: somebody else would find it interesting
Caption: too and so ddd i thought was a really
Caption: good conference to submit this to since
Caption: you have to vote the talk in and you did
Caption: so clearly at least you know two people
Caption: found this interesting um so thank you
Caption: for voting
Caption: um and the but the main reason that i
Caption: wanted to give this talk other than i'm
Caption: just a bit of a nerd about it is i have
Caption: spent a considerable portion of my
Caption: career working with people who are new
Caption: to tech so whether they're new
Caption: developers or people who are just
Caption: generally not quite comfortable using
Caption: their computer yet
Caption: and so that experience has taught me
Caption: that there are some remarkable
Caption: misconceptions that exist about our
Caption: industry and more specifically today
Caption: computers themselves
Caption: so a lot of people struggle with
Caption: confidence when they start learning how
Caption: to how to code or even just learning how
Caption: to use a new tool on their computer and
Caption: so many people have this idea that
Caption: computers are these magical all-knowing
Caption: beings and that they'll shame us if we
Caption: make a mistake but this is absolutely
Caption: not the case in fact computers are super
Caption: dumb
Caption: they are just
Caption: super dumb boxes of middle there is
Caption: literally nothing else to them
Caption: they are absolute perfectionist as the
Caption: developers in the room will know you
Caption: miss a semicolon they fall apart they
Caption: have a tantrum sometimes they get cranky
Caption: if they haven't had enough sleep and you
Caption: just have to turn them off and on again
Caption: to fix them like seriously these things
Caption: are not smart and we put way too much we
Caption: just give them way too much kudos
Caption: sometimes
Caption: so they're boxes of metal they literally
Caption: know nothing other than what we tell
Caption: them
Caption: um but that's also actually what makes
Caption: them useful so using computers does make
Caption: our lives easier for the most part but
Caption: that is absolutely not an accident
Caption: so humans build computers for humans so
Caption: they exist to solve our problems that is
Caption: that is exactly why they exist and
Caption: nothing about the way that they work is
Caption: a coincidence
Caption: which is why i wanted to talk about
Caption: color
Caption: so today i'm going to take you on a
Caption: little journey about uh to prove to you
Caption: that the way color works on a computer
Caption: and the way computers work it's not a
Caption: coincidence at all it's in fact very
Caption: clever it's very smart humans were the
Caption: ones who came up with it and it benefits
Caption: us humans greatly
Caption: so
Caption: what are we actually going to talk about
Caption: today um we'll start with there's going
Caption: to be a lot of emoji
Caption: so
Caption: my advice to you right now would be get
Caption: really comfy there is way more in this
Caption: than you would think which is why this
Caption: is a 45 minute talk and i feel like i
Caption: could have added three more days to it
Caption: if i really wanted to
Caption: so we're going to talk about how mixing
Caption: colors work which you might have figured
Caption: out based on the fact that there is
Caption: paint in front of me right now
Caption: we're also going to look at the physics
Caption: of light which you may have noticed
Caption: there are some torches on the table in
Caption: front of me as well
Caption: we're going to talk a little bit about
Caption: biology so we're going to understand a
Caption: little bit more about how our eyes work
Caption: and how that lets us perceive different
Caption: colors and then we're going to bring
Caption: that together with a little bit of
Caption: computer science so computer science is
Caption: going to tie those things together for
Caption: us and eventually we're going to look at
Caption: how color codes work in css
Caption: so those things that we type in our css
Caption: files or our designers use we're going
Caption: to have a look at how those things
Caption: actually work and how all of this
Caption: came to end up as some code that we can
Caption: write in css
Caption: so
Caption: i always i tend to give workshops more
Caption: than i give talks and so my workshops
Caption: are always super interactive and so i
Caption: kind of couldn't help myself and so
Caption: that's why well this is with me today um
Caption: so
Caption: for this talk i would love for you to
Caption: put yourself in or to start with at
Caption: least in the mindset of a kindergarten
Caption: student so imagine you're four or five
Caption: six years old and you're learning about
Caption: paints and colors for the first time
Caption: but then we're quickly gonna ramp up so
Caption: we're gonna start at kindergarten and
Caption: we're gonna go probably as far as first
Caption: year uni when we get to the computer
Caption: science stuff so like we're covering
Caption: quite a range here today
Caption: now speaking of um kindergarten
Caption: uh
Caption: i think we should start playing with
Caption: some paint
Caption: uh
Caption: so i'm just i'm just a little bit too
Caption: excited so i'm just gonna start getting
Caption: into the paint i think all right let's
Caption: do this so paint think back to
Caption: kindergarten or primary school you might
Caption: you might remember about learning about
Caption: mixing paints and this thing called a
Caption: color wheel
Caption: so the idea of a color wheel is to show
Caption: how colors relate to each other so i
Caption: found a simple color wheel
Caption: with the idea it shows how one color
Caption: might slowly transition to the other
Caption: until you've done a full 360. but then i
Caption: thought that's super boring and paint's
Caption: super fun so let's do this with paint
Caption: instead
Caption: so i brought
Caption: some paint with me today
Caption: and i would just like to get some
Caption: expectations cleared up right now i'm
Caption: not an artist in any way i am no bob
Caption: ross whatever you're expecting like
Caption: lower your standards considerably it's
Caption: blobs we're just going for some blobs
Caption: that's all we're doing today
Caption: okay i brought some uh
Caption: red
Caption: yellow and blue paint with me
Caption: but the problem is when you're painting
Caption: uh
Caption: i know nothing about paint but i assume
Caption: that often you want more than three
Caption: colors but i only have these three
Caption: colors with me just gonna hide that
Caption: black one for now i only have these
Caption: three colors with me
Caption: but fortunately because i know about
Caption: this thing called the color wheel i
Caption: could use these colors
Caption: to make new colors if i wanted to so
Caption: i'm going to get mixing
Caption: so i'm going to put a little bit of blue
Caption: and can you tell i've already used it
Caption: like my fingers are blue already so i'm
Caption: going to put a little bit of blue in
Caption: this bowl
Caption: i just really like this shirt and i
Caption: don't want paint on it because i'm just
Caption: going to stand like this okay so i've
Caption: got a little bit of blue a little bit of
Caption: yellow
Caption: and then i'm just going to go ahead and
Caption: mix these up
Caption: so when i mix these i get green
Caption: i'm i'm really hoping that this wasn't
Caption: particularly shocking but i also know
Caption: that i told you to think like you're a
Caption: kindergarten student so maybe this is so
Caption: i mixed in blue and yellow and i got
Caption: green cool what else can i do
Caption: and apologies
Caption: for the smell of paint
Caption: that is going to fill this room
Caption: it's a lot alright so
Caption: next i'm going to mix some yellow and
Caption: red so i can get my yellow
Caption: and some red
Caption: and let's make this these up as well
Caption: okay so i mix yellow and red
Caption: and i get a pretty good orange pretty
Caption: happy with that cool
Caption: thank you for the chair
Caption: well it's pretty mind-blowing right like
Caption: i'm having fun like
Caption: okay the last combination that i'm gonna
Caption: do is my red and blue which already has
Caption: some green on it so you know i'm off to
Caption: a really good start
Caption: okay
Caption: i'm just the goal is to not get any on
Caption: my laptop but
Caption: it's gonna happen all right so i got the
Caption: telstra
Caption: i'm sure that would be uh oh like but
Caption: i mean i don't have to come back so that
Caption: doesn't sound like my problem
Caption: all right
Caption: so
Caption: i'm gonna mix my red and blue
Caption: and i get a purple
Caption: cool pretty dark purple these are pretty
Caption: dark um colors that i'm starting with
Caption: cool
Caption: so i'm going to put that down for a
Caption: moment before i get that on me again
Caption: all right so these three colors that i'm
Caption: using to create new colors at the moment
Caption: uh we would call them primary colors and
Caption: they're actually the prime oh i'm some
Caption: pretty diagrams my apologies and these
Caption: are actually the primary colors from the
Caption: ryb color model just very creatively
Caption: named ryb red yellow blue
Caption: now a color model is any system that
Caption: uses three primary colors to create new
Caption: colors as we just tested out
Caption: but if i wanted to so i made these
Caption: secondary colors if i wanted to
Caption: i could make some tertiary colors as
Caption: well so the next ones are long so if i
Caption: mix a primary and a secondary i get a
Caption: tertiary so i'm going to mix some more
Caption: blue
Caption: into my green so my green came from blue
Caption: and yellow
Caption: and it's now a secondary and if i add a
Caption: little bit more blue to it
Caption: this is so much more paint on my hands
Caption: than i was expecting today
Caption: and then i mix this up
Caption: then i'm going to get like a teal kind
Caption: of you call it teal yeah i feel like
Caption: it's still
Caption: so i've just created another color now
Caption: so from the three colors that i brought
Caption: with me
Caption: uh i have made a bunch of new colors so
Caption: i made um some green which i've turned
Caption: into teal i made purple i made orange so
Caption: from that i managed to make three
Caption: secondaries in a tertiary now i could
Caption: keep going but i won't don't worry um
Caption: but i could keep going and make as many
Caption: colors as i wanted
Caption: within reason and the extent of all the
Caption: colors or all the possible colors that i
Caption: could make is called a gamut
Caption: so when no matter what i uh what i mix
Caption: when if i use these three paints
Caption: whatever colors i make all the
Caption: possibilities collectively that's called
Caption: a gamut of
Caption: colors but if i say change one of these
Caption: paints so if i decided i didn't like
Caption: this yellow and i swapped it out for a
Caption: different brand or just a slightly
Caption: different shade then that'll affect the
Caption: colors that i can make and so that would
Caption: change my gamut and i would be able to
Caption: make a slightly different gamut of
Caption: colors
Caption: okay cool story haley where are you
Caption: going with this
Caption: i want to say before i get too carried
Caption: away with playing with paint but like
Caption: i'm having a great time so we're there
Caption: um
Caption: let's
Caption: let's take a step back and try and
Caption: understand uh why we can even see these
Caption: colors in the first place
Caption: so we're gonna have to get just a little
Caption: bit physically to understand what's
Caption: going on here so we're done with
Caption: kindergarten now we're moving on up
Caption: so
Caption: i want you to think about light
Caption: uh specifically
Caption: maybe the light coming from these bowls
Caption: or the light bouncing off these bowls so
Caption: when we think of light uh what we
Caption: actually mean is visible electromagnetic
Caption: radiation
Caption: which is a
Caption: very fancy word from a very fancy
Caption: physics idea that basically is referring
Caption: to the electromagnetic spectrum which is
Caption: the range of frequencies covered by
Caption: electromagnetic radiation and it's
Caption: broken down by different bands of
Caption: frequencies so gamma x-ray uv visible
Caption: infrared microwave radio
Caption: so
Caption: the radiation travels in waves all these
Caption: things are traveling these things called
Caption: waves so when we say frequency we're
Caption: actually referring to how fast a wave is
Caption: moving so
Caption: uh we've got
Caption: faster waves down here we've got solar
Caption: waves on the right
Caption: now if you're
Caption: uh oh and this is an example just to
Caption: help you visualize it just you know if
Caption: you didn't know what a wave looked like
Caption: here you go um so if you're interested
Caption: the more detailed explanation is that
Caption: we're measuring how many wavelengths
Caption: past a fixed point in a specific period
Caption: of time a wavelength being the distance
Caption: between uh two points so two crests or
Caption: two peaks in a wave
Caption: now back to the spectrum so uh on the
Caption: spectrum uh visible light so stuff that
Caption: we as humans can see is super super tiny
Caption: so we can only see this little little
Caption: tiny patch in the middle but inside that
Caption: inside that little range on the
Caption: electromagnetic spectrum there's
Caption: actually still a decent range of waves
Caption: so
Caption: these different wavelengths are actually
Caption: what influence our perception of color
Caption: so when we experience seeing red we're
Caption: seeing a long wavelength and when we're
Caption: experiencing
Caption: violence we're seeing a shorter
Caption: wavelength relatively speaking
Caption: so the frequency or the wavelength of a
Caption: wave is what determines the color that
Caption: we actually see
Caption: but what is the connection between those
Caption: waves and this paint
Caption: well at the moment
Caption: i have a white canvas
Caption: and this canvas is reflecting every
Caption: single wavelength of light equally which
Caption: is why i see it as white
Caption: so
Caption: all the visible light to us humans hits
Caption: it and it bounces off equally the canvas
Caption: is absorbing none of it and so we see
Caption: white because that's the result of
Caption: combining all of those colors together
Caption: but if i add some paint to this
Caption: so if i take a little bit of
Caption: this teal
Caption: or this tertiary that we made earlier
Caption: and i add some paint to my canvas well
Caption: now i can see
Caption: teal on my canvas i can see white and i
Caption: can see teal so what's happening at this
Caption: point
Caption: is the paint is actually just reflecting
Caption: the blue and green light so
Caption: this has uh yellow it's got a bit of
Caption: green
Caption: which came from yellow and blue and then
Caption: it got a bit more blue so this stripe on
Caption: the canvas is just reflecting those
Caption: colors and absorbing every other color
Caption: which is why i can see it so it reflects
Caption: it it goes to my eyes i can see it
Caption: put that back down
Caption: okay
Caption: so what's also interesting is if i mix
Caption: all of these paints together
Caption: i can get black
Caption: now
Caption: yesterday i covered my kitchen in
Caption: several different shades of nearly black
Caption: and i learned that it takes quite a bit
Caption: of precision to get actual perfect black
Caption: so i cheat i'm cheating today and i
Caption: brought some black with me
Caption: um
Caption: probably didn't need its own bowl but
Caption: there we go
Caption: so i've got some black paint here it's
Caption: very black i i came really close but i
Caption: just couldn't quite get it so when i put
Caption: black paint on my canvas now
Caption: this is now the total opposite to white
Caption: so white reflects every single
Caption: wavelength and so when those colors
Caption: combine we see that as white meanwhile
Caption: black is absorbing every single
Caption: wavelength
Caption: so in other words it's not actually
Caption: reflecting any color so stuff's hitting
Caption: the black and it's been completely
Caption: absorbed and i can't see it anymore so
Caption: it's there is no color for me to see
Caption: there the black is absorbing it
Caption: so this process where i start with a
Caption: white canvas
Caption: and i've added paint to it this is
Caption: called subtractive color mixing so i
Caption: started with a surface that reflects
Caption: every single color and i slowly took
Caption: away from it so i added some teal and i
Caption: added some black so this is subtractive
Caption: start with lots of color slowly remove
Caption: it
Caption: okay
Caption: cool
Caption: so
Caption: let me skip ahead a few here we go
Caption: um
Caption: so i've talked a little bit about how
Caption: light moves around we've looked at how
Caption: paint mixes together so what is the
Caption: connection between
Caption: uh when i say that reflects off and it
Caption: goes to our eyes what do i actually mean
Caption: like how do we actually see this thing
Caption: so we're gonna go into a little bit of
Caption: biology now
Caption: so this is what an
Caption: this is what an eye looks like
Caption: um so if you look like really deeply
Caption: into your partner's eyes this is what
Caption: you'll see
Caption: and there are several different
Caption: interesting parts of the eye so at the
Caption: front we have this iris so that's the
Caption: colorful part of the eye so if your eyes
Caption: blue or brown or green or whatever that
Caption: part's called the iris
Caption: inside the iris is the pupil um that's a
Caption: little black spot in the middle i think
Caption: of it as the hole that sucks in all the
Caption: light um
Caption: so that is inside the iris so inside
Caption: that colorful part that little hole in
Caption: the middle that's the pupil
Caption: in front of the iris is the cornea so
Caption: the iris and the pupil have a really
Caption: important job of letting light in and so
Caption: in front of them they have this thing
Caption: called a cornea which is a protective
Caption: layer so the cornea stops uh any like
Caption: dust or germs or just any particles that
Caption: you don't want in your eye the cornea is
Caption: what stops them from getting in there
Caption: on the other side of the iris on the
Caption: inside of the eye is the lens
Caption: and so the cornea and the lens actually
Caption: work together to focus on things at
Caption: different distances so when they work
Caption: together well that's what lets you see
Caption: say your hand right in front of you and
Caption: your friend on the other side of the
Caption: room
Caption: so the way they do that is they bend or
Caption: refract light so that it goes into your
Caption: eye and it hits the retina
Caption: so the retina is like squishy tissue
Caption: that covers the back of the eye about 60
Caption: 70 of the back of your eyes covered in
Caption: this thing called the retina
Caption: um and the retina's job is
Caption: uh
Caption: to receive light that comes from the
Caption: cornea and the lens and then convert it
Caption: to electrical neural impulses
Caption: and then those are sent to the brain by
Caption: this thing called the optic nerve but
Caption: now we're getting like a little bit too
Caption: far away so let's just come back all
Caption: right the retina
Caption: so
Caption: uh
Caption: the retina contains millions of these uh
Caption: cells called photoreceptor cells
Caption: um there are two kinds of photoreceptor
Caption: cells so we either have uh all right so
Caption: we have both rods and cones um we're
Caption: gonna look at each of these individually
Caption: and we're gonna start with cones
Caption: so
Caption: we have three kinds of cones so we're
Caption: thinking about the retina it's filled
Caption: with tons of cells there are two kinds
Caption: of cells one of those cells is the cones
Caption: and then there are three kinds of cones
Caption: so we have s m and l cones
Caption: um
Caption: so the names aren't actually based on
Caption: the size of the cone which is what i
Caption: thought when i first looked it up it
Caption: actually corresponds to the wavelengths
Caption: that they're sensitive to so remember
Caption: earlier when we were looking at
Caption: different wavelengths to see different
Caption: colors turns out our eyes are sensitive
Caption: to different wavelengths so when we say
Caption: esem and alkones we mean um
Caption: short
Caption: uh we mean short medium and long cones
Caption: and that corresponds to short medium or
Caption: long wavelengths relatively speaking
Caption: so because they correspond so well to
Caption: these different colors so the blue green
Caption: and red we actually tend to generalize
Caption: them to blue green and red
Caption: cones all right back to the paint
Caption: so
Caption: i said that we could see this teal or
Caption: technically its name is blue green we
Caption: could see this blue green paint um
Caption: reflecting off the canvas and hitting
Caption: our eyes so what's actually happening
Caption: when it gets to our eyes is that
Caption: stimulating our ism in cones so they're
Caption: being stimulated uh red is not and so
Caption: that's what lets us see
Caption: sorry the red's not been stimulated all
Caption: the long cones are not being stimulated
Caption: which is what lets us see that color is
Caption: teal or blue green
Caption: but as an aside
Caption: we are not actually created all equal
Caption: so not all of us see colors uh the same
Caption: so for some people
Caption: some people have color vision
Caption: deficiencies um otherwise known as are
Caption: color blind and there is like a million
Caption: different variations of what that means
Caption: so some of us have trouble detecting
Caption: differences between colors or we just
Caption: can't detect color at all
Caption: this can happen when there are defects
Caption: in the cone cells and that could be say
Caption: from surgery or it could be genetic
Caption: there's a bunch of different reasons
Caption: but even if you don't have a color
Caption: deficiency you still actually experience
Caption: color in your own unique way
Caption: so we do not all have the same number of
Caption: cones so we don't all have the same
Caption: number of red green and blue cones so
Caption: the blue that i see might not actually
Caption: be the same blue that you see
Caption: um but there'll be tiny minute
Caption: differences but yeah everybody sees
Caption: color differently which i thought was
Caption: really interesting
Caption: anyway
Caption: the ism and all cones
Caption: so
Caption: they themselves are also not evenly
Caption: distributed so we have way more m l
Caption: cones than we do s cones
Caption: so that is we have way more green and
Caption: blue green and red cones and not very
Caption: many blue cones
Caption: and this is actually um relates to
Caption: seeing in the dark
Caption: so
Caption: cone cells are sensitive to color but
Caption: they are not so sensitive to light and
Caption: there is a difference
Caption: so this is why we have rod cells
Caption: uh we have so i see we have about six to
Caption: seven million cone cells but we have
Caption: about 120 million rod cells and the rod
Caption: cells job is to help us see in the dark
Caption: so when we are in uh lower levels of
Caption: light we're more sensitive
Caption: of wavelengths closer to blue but when
Caption: we're in brighter lights we're more
Caption: sensitive to wavelengths of
Caption: green and red because
Caption: the cone cells
Caption: they they can't deal with it when
Caption: there's not much light and so if you
Caption: think about it at night time there's
Caption: even like a blue tint kind of or if if
Caption: you pick up a blue object and an orange
Caption: object
Caption: you won't be able to see the orange
Caption: object as well as you could see the blue
Caption: and that's why it's because we our cone
Caption: cells are really terrible in low light
Caption: and that's where our broad cells come in
Caption: so we see a blue tint at night instead
Caption: and again that'll vary between um
Caption: different people because we have a
Caption: different number of conan rod cells and
Caption: also i guess based on how many carrots
Caption: you've eaten recently
Caption: all right
Caption: speaking of light or more specifically
Caption: seeing in the dark
Caption: we've played with paint and next i'm
Caption: really excited
Caption: to have a play with
Caption: mixing colors using light
Caption: so we could turn the lights off
Caption: all right so i have with me um some
Caption: different torches
Caption: yeah and i'm gonna use them um to make
Caption: different colors so
Caption: i say different color torches like it's
Caption: they're white torches with cellophane on
Caption: them um so i have with me i've got a red
Caption: and a blue so when i put them on the
Caption: wall together so i've got my red i've
Caption: got my blue but when i mix them together
Caption: i get magenta
Caption: just super pretty
Caption: if i
Caption: mix if i take my red
Caption: and yellow sorry my red and green i
Caption: should be able to get a yellow there we
Caption: go
Caption: kind of orange yellow there in the
Caption: middle
Caption: uh and if i take uh my
Caption: green and blue
Caption: there we go then i should be able to get
Caption: cyan
Caption: very cool
Caption: and then if i mix all of them um could i
Caption: have a hand since you just walked in
Caption: could you could you face this just hold
Caption: it on the wall for me yeah
Caption: okay if we add all of these we should be
Caption: able to get a white in the middle there
Caption: we go
Caption: very cool thank you
Caption: great timing or bad timing to be near
Caption: how you feel about being in a demo
Caption: okay uh we can turn the lights back
Caption: um
Caption: okay
Caption: it suddenly feels really bright in here
Caption: just a trick to like wake you all up i'm
Caption: certainly awake
Caption: okay so
Caption: what did we just do so basically i took
Caption: three primary colors um
Caption: that's a lie this is the rgb model so
Caption: red green blue again very creatively
Caption: named i took three colors mix them
Caption: together on the wall to create new
Caption: colors so to make some new secondary
Caption: colors
Caption: um so what's actually happening when we
Caption: did that is now that we know about eyes
Caption: we were actually stimulating different
Caption: cones in our eyes so the light hits the
Caption: wall it's reflected off the wall it goes
Caption: to our eyes and we out because of the
Caption: different cones that we have so whether
Caption: we have red red green and blue cones we
Caption: see different colors
Caption: now
Caption: previously when we were playing with
Caption: paint i mixed red yellow and blue and
Caption: gold black well i mixed red yellow and
Caption: blue i used some black paint and i got
Caption: black
Caption: um
Caption: but now when i'm playing with these
Caption: torches and i get and i mix red green
Caption: and blue i see white so with paint when
Caption: i mixed my three primaries i got black
Caption: but with my lights when i mixed my three
Caption: primaries i got white
Caption: so our canvas started white and had uh
Caption: color subtracted from it meanwhile when
Caption: i play with my lights we'd call this
Caption: additive so my wall started we'll call
Caption: it black since we were in the dark
Caption: and i added color to it so it goes in
Caption: the opposite way
Caption: and a fun side note about that there's
Caption: actually a pointless ongoing debate
Caption: between experts as to whether or not
Caption: white or black are technically colours
Caption: because they work in this opposite
Caption: way i wonder if i made a slide to show
Caption: you this
Caption: maybe here we go all right
Caption: so
Caption: uh when we're thinking about the light
Caption: uh all com sorry when we're thinking
Caption: about light white is the combination of
Caption: all colors so they're being added
Caption: together to make this color white so in
Caption: that case we'd consider yeah white's a
Caption: color that makes sense
Caption: meanwhile black is the absence of color
Caption: so i put some black paint on the canvas
Caption: and we couldn't see any other color
Caption: anymore so we'd say no
Caption: black is
Caption: i feel like that's wrong
Caption: black is not a color
Caption: but if we're thinking of color as paint
Caption: it's the uh
Caption: sorry
Caption: past haley was right
Caption: sleep deprived haley today was wrong
Caption: this is correct so when we're playing
Caption: with light on the wall and we don't have
Caption: any torches on the wall uh we see black
Caption: depending on how dark the room is um and
Caption: so we would not consider black of color
Caption: now playing with paint it's the other
Caption: way around so
Caption: i cannot mix
Caption: uh paint together to generate white we
Caption: cannot mix paint together to generate
Caption: white it's not something that we can do
Caption: so in this case we would consider white
Caption: the absence of color and so we would say
Caption: white is not a color
Caption: but meanwhile
Caption: we can combine different colors or
Caption: different primaries of paints to get
Caption: black so we'd say yeah black's a color
Caption: that makes sense but then just to make
Caption: everything a little bit more difficult
Caption: um if you talk to say someone into
Caption: pigment chemistry they'll say oh but
Caption: haley we could bleach the canvas to make
Caption: it white so surely that makes it a color
Caption: right
Caption: and this is where the argument comes in
Caption: i was like i've been doing some deep
Caption: dives in the internet this week okay
Caption: all right all right coming back to
Caption: computers because i promised that this
Caption: was going to be somewhat relevant to you
Caption: today
Caption: so
Caption: i feel like hopefully we've got a pretty
Caption: good understanding of how colors work
Caption: and how we can mix colors so i've did
Caption: that with pigments or paints here i did
Caption: that with torches on the wall how does
Caption: this connect to computers well
Caption: we were playing with torches earlier and
Caption: that is the connection between
Caption: all of this and your computer screen
Caption: so you can think of your computer screen
Caption: as being this huge grid
Caption: um and so each cell in this cruise
Caption: is one tiny element of a picture that we
Caption: might see and again i'm not an artist
Caption: but i made us a little picture so
Caption: imagine this is a grid on your computer
Caption: it's filled with all these tiny cells
Caption: and then each of these cells we would
Caption: call a picture element otherwise known
Caption: as a pixel
Caption: and then if we look at one of these
Caption: pixels
Caption: really close
Caption: really close we can see that it's made
Caption: of three lights so it's got a red light
Caption: it's got a green light and it's got a
Caption: blue light and in this case my picture
Caption: was blue or that cell was blue so only
Caption: the blue light is turned on
Caption: so computer screens actually use the rgb
Caption: color model just like i was using when i
Caption: was playing with these torches on the
Caption: wall
Caption: so
Caption: when i zoomed in on one of these pixels
Caption: i can see my rgmb so i can see the three
Caption: other three lights acting there in this
Caption: case again blue's turned on because i'm
Caption: showing a blue pixel
Caption: so with that in mind
Caption: imagine this circle represents all the
Caption: visible colors of light so these are all
Caption: the colors that we could possibly see as
Caption: humans
Caption: rgb
Caption: represents a very specific subset of
Caption: that
Caption: um so rgb being
Caption: this one here this big yellow one so we
Caption: can't actually generate every single
Caption: color uh
Caption: using rgb but we can generate a lot like
Caption: it's enough
Caption: uh rgb is actually so we'd call it a
Caption: color model as we touched on earlier and
Caption: then inside these color models we can
Caption: make color spaces so this is an example
Caption: of a color space it's called srgb
Caption: honestly these names like they are not
Caption: creative at all and that stands for
Caption: standard rgb
Caption: uh was created by hp and microsoft i
Caption: told you would come back to tech
Caption: in 1996 for use on monitors so this is
Caption: the very widely used standard for what
Caption: colors will display on monitors
Caption: so these days esrgb very very widely
Caption: used even though it was created a very
Caption: long time ago unless you have a modern
Caption: apple device in which case you'll be
Caption: seeing display p3 because apple
Caption: so because of that we would say rgb is a
Caption: device dependent model because
Caption: manufacturers use slightly different
Caption: color spaces based off rgb and also
Caption: there'll be slight variations
Caption: in the materials used by the actual
Caption: manufacturers when they build the
Caption: screens
Caption: so that means that the gamut of colors
Caption: that can be produced on a screen will
Caption: vary ever so slightly between different
Caption: screens so that's why if you look at
Caption: your phone you compare it to your
Caption: friend's phone and you think hang on
Caption: this is the same picture how come it
Caption: looks different on yours that's why it's
Caption: because they might be using a different
Caption: gamut or they might just be made of
Caption: different materials or both
Caption: now it's not a coincidence that rgb is
Caption: the preferred color model for computers
Caption: it's because it's the way our cones
Caption: perceive color so it is absolutely not a
Caption: coincidence that we were chatting about
Caption: cones and whatnot earlier um and it's
Caption: not a coincidence that that's the colors
Caption: that computers choose to use it's
Caption: because it matches human biology we
Caption: build these things for us remember and
Caption: so they're going to use what matches our
Caption: biology
Caption: so
Caption: rgb this is really the theme of i feel
Caption: like i need to rename this talk which is
Caption: rgb what is it
Caption: so i have mentioned um read green and
Caption: blue like a lot and i'm hoping for the
Caption: developers and the designers in the room
Caption: that combination of colors is sounding
Caption: really really familiar but in case it's
Caption: not or web development is not your usual
Caption: thing
Caption: let me jog your memory
Caption: so i have made the world's most boring
Caption: web page
Caption: there is nothing on it other than a
Caption: color and i oh that's what i'm talking
Caption: about it's blue here it kind of looks
Caption: purple to me there this is what i'm
Caption: saying people
Caption: so
Caption: uh
Caption: this webpage has nothing on it but a
Caption: background color and i defined that
Caption: using css and i can show that to you as
Caption: well if i can find my cursor here
Caption: oh
Caption: that's not what i meant to do or not
Caption: all right
Caption: and yes i can make that bigger
Caption: all right so very simple css all i've
Caption: done is defined the background color and
Caption: i've done that using the rgb function
Caption: so what i'm actually doing when i'm
Caption: using that rgb function is i'm changing
Caption: the intensity of each of
Caption: red green and blue
Caption: and when i say changing the intensity
Caption: what i mean is every pixel that's been
Caption: used to display that web page on the
Caption: screen it's going to look at this and
Caption: say okay how much red do you want how
Caption: much green do you want and how much blue
Caption: do you want
Caption: so the intensity is being defined by
Caption: those values so in this case i've gone
Caption: zero zero two five five which is why
Caption: that web script the web page appears
Caption: blue
Caption: or purple on the screen
Caption: uh and if i wanted uh to say if i wanted
Caption: to make red then i could change those
Caption: values so i could go two five five zero
Caption: zero so i want maximum red i don't want
Caption: any green and i don't want any blue and
Caption: let's see what the screen thing says oh
Caption: that's pretty red that's pretty good
Caption: if i wanted to get a color uh that isn't
Caption: one of my primaries um then i could use
Caption: a combination instead so in this case if
Caption: i wanted to get i think this is purple
Caption: i've got one two eight zero one two
Caption: eight so i'm saying hey i want a little
Caption: bit of red i want a little bit of blue
Caption: but i don't want any green
Caption: now given that blue was purple
Caption: oh it's pretty purple
Caption: oh it kind of looks like someone to my
Caption: hair
Caption: up there anyway
Caption: okay
Caption: so basically what i did just then is i
Caption: said hey i want to use red and blue
Caption: lights but i want each of them at half
Caption: the intensity and so that's how i
Caption: generated my purple so similar to when i
Caption: was playing with these torches except
Caption: they're not cool enough for me to match
Caption: to pick specific intensities but that's
Caption: what i'm doing when i define my rgb in
Caption: my css that's what you're doing when you
Caption: use rgb in your css
Caption: so
Caption: um because i told you that i'm a bit of
Caption: a nerd i would like to focus on these
Caption: numbers so
Caption: have you ever wondered why they go from
Caption: 0 to
Caption: 255 because i don't know about you when
Caption: i first stumbled across that i'm like
Caption: that's a really random number where did
Caption: that come from it turns out it's not
Caption: random it has a lot of meaning behind it
Caption: and we're going to go back to primary
Caption: school days now so we're really going
Caption: all over the show we're going to hop
Caption: back to primary
Caption: um and we're going to learn about the
Caption: decimal number system
Caption: so decimal numbers being the numbers
Caption: that we us humans use um every day
Caption: um and more specifically i mean the
Caption: digits 0 to 9. so these are what make up
Caption: our decimal number system
Caption: so since we have 10 digits to work with
Caption: in our decimal system the largest number
Caption: that we can represent using a single
Caption: digit is 9.
Caption: and then if we want to represent a
Caption: bigger number than that we have to add
Caption: another digit to get 10.
Caption: and then once we get to 99 if i want to
Caption: represent a bigger number i have to add
Caption: another digit
Caption: and i add 1 which lets me get to a
Caption: thousand
Caption: a hundred
Caption: maths
Caption: and if i wanted to get um to a thousand
Caption: then i've got to add another digit so
Caption: now i've got four digits which leave me
Caption: lets me represent a thousand
Caption: the pattern that's happening here is the
Caption: digit on the left is worth 10 times as
Caption: much as the digit on the right so we've
Caption: got ten numbers to work with zero
Caption: through nine and each of these worth ten
Caption: times as much as the digit on the right
Caption: so
Caption: that's what side i was expecting to
Caption: there all right
Caption: so if we take the number 123 for example
Caption: the 1 is worth 10 times as much as the 2
Caption: and the 2 is worth 10 times as much as
Caption: the 3.
Caption: now
Caption: computers remember how i said they're
Caption: super dumb so they can't handle 0 to 9
Caption: for a variety of reasons so instead they
Caption: use a binary system
Caption: or just zero and one so they forget two
Caption: through nine they've just got zero and
Caption: one that's all they've got to work with
Caption: so
Caption: since there are only two options that's
Caption: why we call them binary digits
Caption: and because we're super lazy we shorten
Caption: that and this is where the term bit
Caption: comes from so a bit is a binary digit
Caption: which means zero or one
Caption: so since there are only two digits to
Caption: work with this means that representing
Caption: numbers in binary
Caption: is not the same as how we would in
Caption: decimal it's a little bit trickier so
Caption: rather than
Caption: each digit being worth 10 times as much
Caption: it's digit on the right in binary it's
Caption: worth only two times as much
Caption: so for example in this number one zero
Caption: zero one
Caption: uh our number on the right is worth one
Caption: zero is worth two
Caption: the next zero is worth four and the next
Caption: one is worth eight so it doubles each
Caption: time so previously we went up in tens
Caption: this time we're doubling it
Caption: and if you're wondering uh we can
Caption: definitely work out what this number is
Caption: in binary so the first one is worth one
Caption: so keep one in your mind the next one
Caption: we'd say it's turned off or zero doesn't
Caption: mean anything so we ignore it we ignore
Caption: the next one and then this is worth
Caption: eight eight plus one is nine so this
Caption: number is nine so one zero zero one is
Caption: nine
Caption: in binary
Caption: all right i've got some challenges for
Caption: you so i'm so excited another person
Caption: walked in this room all right
Caption: what does this number represent in
Caption: binary so we have one turned on we don't
Caption: have a two we've got a four we've got an
Caption: eight what is this number
Caption: nailed it all right cool what about this
Caption: one
Caption: four five six seven yes nailed it
Caption: i thought that was a nine on my screen
Caption: like oh no
Caption: okay
Caption: okay what about this
Caption: one seven plus eight is um
Caption: 15 15. perfect this one oh wait here one
Caption: count this one
Caption: i was really hoping for the space in the
Caption: audience that i got it okay sorry would
Caption: that if you're wondering that number was
Caption: eight thousand one hundred and ninety
Caption: one um i didn't work that out i put it
Caption: through a converter all right
Caption: yes
Caption: okay all right i wanna focus on this one
Caption: in particular though so one one one one
Caption: is fifteen
Caption: so we get to 15 by having four bits we'd
Caption: say turned on or we're using four bits
Caption: and what's interesting about that is if
Caption: i wanted to get sata 16 i would have to
Caption: add another bit so at the moment the
Caption: most
Caption: or the highest number that i could
Caption: represent using 4 bits is 15. if i
Caption: wanted 16 i have to add another bit to
Caption: it
Caption: now a throwback to
Caption: our rgb
Caption: so the highest number that we can use
Caption: when we are defining colors in our css
Caption: the highest number that we can use is
Caption: 255. this is not a coincidence so 255 in
Caption: binary is eight bits turned on
Caption: so when we're working with computers
Caption: computers really like eights eight bits
Caption: is called a byte so we're happy with
Caption: this number it's good for us so we use
Caption: zero to 255 because that's eight bits
Caption: now we actually have three components
Caption: though so we've got red green and blue
Caption: each of them have uh eight bits or one
Caption: byte so eight plus eight plus eight
Caption: that's 24 and so this is where the term
Caption: 24 bit color comes from if you've ever
Caption: heard of that before
Caption: now since each bit has two states so in
Caption: this case they're all turned on which is
Caption: why it's worth 255 but each bit has two
Caption: states so it could be zero or one so if
Caption: we have two
Caption: uh to the power of 24 bits that actually
Caption: results in many many colors
Caption: in fact this many colors so about 16.7
Caption: million colors can be represented uh
Caption: using 24-bit color humans can only see
Caption: about 10 million colors uh so this is
Caption: more than enough um so this is the
Caption: answer to the question of why why
Caption: wouldn't you add more bits because it
Caption: would be pointless we as humans we can't
Caption: see it
Caption: okay
Caption: but
Caption: this is not where we started so today we
Caption: have access to 16.7 million colors
Caption: but css started a lot more simple with
Caption: 16 colors and this was them very special
Caption: completely arbitrary
Caption: so in 1995 16 basic colors were defined
Caption: in the html 3.0 spec and they were
Caption: labeled as being in the srgb color space
Caption: which is what monitors today use again
Caption: unless you're apple and we're considered
Caption: the standard 16 colors to be supported
Caption: by windows vga palette so at the time
Caption: that was the most widely used standard
Caption: for screens
Caption: so we had these 16 standard colors and
Caption: then we had 124 extended colors
Caption: and the idea was that these 16 standard
Caption: colors you could use them anywhere they
Caption: always had to work they always had to
Caption: look the same um and in the other
Caption: 124 probably be okay
Caption: and it was mostly okay um unless you
Caption: used opera 3.5 on windows 98 in which
Caption: case 14 colors were randomly missing
Caption: i didn't think it was that funny you
Caption: guys really threw me there okay
Caption: um
Caption: all right fortunately um by 2005 um all
Caption: modern browsers supported the full list
Caption: so happy days um we weren't limited by
Caption: um 16 we could have the full 140 of them
Caption: um also interestingly when i was looking
Caption: this up in the spec in css 2.1 orange
Caption: got promoted to the top 16 so we had 17
Caption: basic colors and 139 extended colors and
Caption: then in css 3 it got cut again so i
Caption: don't know what that's about it was
Caption: there and then it was demoted i don't
Caption: know why i just i just thought that was
Caption: amusing
Caption: but meanwhile now in the working draft
Caption: for the css level four color module
Caption: they've just combined both lists so we
Caption: just now have just one standard list
Caption: rather than these two separates
Caption: but
Caption: where did these names come from and what
Caption: do they mean
Caption: well this was a journey learning about
Caption: this let me tell you
Caption: so
Caption: uh in 1984
Caption: um a windows system came out called x
Caption: windows system
Caption: and with that windowing system so when i
Caption: say window like imagine you've got a
Caption: bunch of windows on your screen that you
Caption: can move around like this is that that
Caption: was the software's whole job and so with
Caption: this software it came with a list a file
Caption: called rgb.txt
Caption: and so inside this text file was a bunch
Caption: of colors and by 1987 this was pretty
Caption: popular software it was really well used
Caption: and the rgb.txt was now a list of 69
Caption: colors
Caption: and so that list eventually became a
Caption: commonly used list of colors because
Caption: people would build stuff to be used by
Caption: the software so they thought hey i'll
Caption: just use the same color and then
Caption: designers would be like hey this is
Caption: getting this is like this seems to be
Caption: really popular a lot of people are using
Caption: these i'll just use these colors too but
Caption: there was no real
Caption: standard
Caption: it was just kind of what people felt
Caption: like doing and maybe they didn't feel
Caption: like using that one so they wouldn't
Caption: include it in their list and it was just
Caption: all a bit of a mess which is what led me
Caption: to find this extract from the css spec
Caption: and you don't read all of it let me let
Caption: me show you my favorite parts
Caption: so
Caption: these color names are standardized here
Caption: not because they're good but because
Caption: their use and implementation has been
Caption: widespread
Caption: um my other favorite part the names are
Caption: not even internally consistent dark gray
Caption: is lighter than gray while light pink is
Caption: darker than pink so basically this thing
Caption: was a mess
Caption: um
Caption: sorry this is not you it's me
Caption: you're good
Caption: um
Caption: so basically this list was all over the
Caption: show it was a mess different colors
Caption: meant different things
Caption: based on which computer you were on that
Caption: these names were not thought through
Caption: they were never intended to become as
Caption: widely uh used as they were software was
Caption: built that used it designers got used to
Caption: it it just got out of hand
Caption: but
Caption: eventually we decided we needed a list
Caption: we needed some standard colors and we
Caption: made some headway so in the 1990s most
Caption: displays were capable of displaying
Caption: 256 colors
Caption: wild
Caption: so operating systems
Caption: would often reserve between 16 and 20
Caption: colors for their own use so that
Caption: limited us a little bit and it meant
Caption: that uh
Caption: so admit that we lit
Caption: this problem was wild so
Caption: we had 256 colors we could see on a
Caption: screen which might vary between monitors
Caption: but then some operating systems would
Caption: pick between 16 and 20 colors that they
Caption: would just claim as their own and make
Caption: them look different and so what would
Caption: happen is if you opened up an image on a
Caption: computer that didn't have a reference
Caption: for that color the computer would be
Caption: like no worries i'll just add some noise
Caption: and cover up that hole and so it would
Caption: just
Caption: it would just throw some noise at the
Caption: picture in this method called differing
Caption: just to like just ignore the problem and
Caption: hope you wouldn't notice that was
Caption: literally what they did
Caption: so basically there was no consistency
Caption: between monitors operating systems or
Caption: browsers colors were a mess
Caption: and this is where web safe colors came
Caption: in this was a standardized list of 216
Caption: colors that we could use on the web
Caption: guaranteed to work
Caption: computers monitors software browsers all
Caption: of it they all had to use these web safe
Caption: colors
Caption: but just after we got that list
Caption: we introduced true color or 24 bit color
Caption: and we didn't need it anymore so just as
Caption: we got this list of standard colors
Caption: after like a 20 year wait already gone
Caption: doesn't matter we now have 16.7 million
Caption: colors who cares don't need web safe
Caption: anymore so it was a long journey an
Caption: absolutely pointless one
Caption: never mind
Caption: all right
Caption: so coming back to css i would love for
Caption: us to chat about hex codes because this
Caption: is actually what inspired this whole
Caption: talk
Caption: so if you haven't seen a hex code before
Caption: this is another way to define color that
Caption: we use in css and i'm sure designers
Caption: will see this as well
Caption: so here are four different colors here
Caption: are four different hex codes to
Caption: represent each of those colors
Caption: and they work really similar to the way
Caption: rgb does as well
Caption: so
Caption: let's have a closer
Caption: look oh and just a side note those
Caption: colors that we were just chatting about
Caption: um and these hex codes they all map to
Caption: rgb anyway so this is just like picking
Caption: a different way to define the same color
Caption: but obviously there's not a list of 16.7
Caption: million colors so at some point you've
Caption: got to commit to rgb or hex um because
Caption: that list is not gonna that's not gonna
Caption: work
Caption: okay
Caption: so
Caption: um let's unpack these so i'm gonna look
Caption: at that purple one so 5f3a8e
Caption: what the heck is happening there
Caption: so
Caption: basically hex codes are broken down into
Caption: three components so there's a red
Caption: component a green component and a blue
Caption: component
Caption: um so we're going to translate this
Caption: to binary to understand
Caption: what is going on here and how this
Caption: actually becomes a color
Caption: so let's look at this um
Caption: let's look at the red component first
Caption: so hexadecimal uses a
Caption: 16 a base 16 numbering system so
Caption: computers use base two humans use base
Caption: 10 hexadecimals like lol or low let's
Caption: use base 16.
Caption: but we as humans we only have 10 numbers
Caption: to work with or 10 digits to work with
Caption: and this is where the letters come in so
Caption: once we get to 10 us humans we go okay
Caption: no worries we got an alphabet it's all
Caption: good so this is where a through f comes
Caption: in and that's why you can't go past f
Caption: it's because we've reached 15
Caption: hexadecimal being base 16 that's all we
Caption: need
Caption: so um let's look at the
Caption: uh red component of the purple color
Caption: here so i've got the um his decimal
Caption: reference at the top to help us out so
Caption: when i've got um
Caption: five so i'm just going to look at that
Caption: first five initially
Caption: this is it in binary so 0 1 0 1. awesome
Caption: when i get to the f
Caption: i have to check my little reference at
Caption: the top here so f is 15 or the maximum
Caption: that we can use which means all four
Caption: bits are turned on 1 1 1 1. awesome
Caption: we've converted red same with green so
Caption: we've got three a three uh
Caption: we already have that number so we don't
Caption: need to map it to a letter um a however
Caption: has to be represented by 10 and in
Caption: binary these look like come on look like
Caption: this and same with
Caption: b
Caption: so
Caption: that is the mapping from the hexadecimal
Caption: to binary
Caption: the reason that we have hexadecimal is
Caption: exactly so that we don't have to write
Caption: this out so hexadecimal is actually just
Caption: a shorthand for binary it's not special
Caption: to colors it's just a really common
Caption: place where we use it so usually when we
Caption: say hex codes as developers we're
Caption: probably referring to this but it's just
Caption: a shorthand it's it's just coincidence
Caption: that that's where we most commonly use
Caption: it
Caption: so
Caption: i would like to point out here that each
Caption: of these components so that r g and b
Caption: those are each using eight bits so
Caption: together that's 24 bits
Caption: and so just like our rgb color we have a
Caption: 24 bit color again and so these can be
Caption: mapped between each other so this is why
Caption: you're able to google like rgb to hex
Caption: code or vice versa it's because
Caption: underneath the hood it's all just binary
Caption: that we've been uh that we're converting
Caption: between the two of them and as far as
Caption: css is concerned it doesn't matter which
Caption: one you use it's just going to convert
Caption: it to binary anyway so it's really about
Caption: personal preference
Caption: and rgb and hex are really commonly used
Caption: because hex is like you know super easy
Caption: to copy paste rgb is really easy to use
Caption: because if you know that it's the red
Caption: green and blue component you could tweak
Caption: the numbers
Caption: in your head without having to look it
Caption: up depends how much of a nerd you are i
Caption: don't know i do that
Caption: um
Caption: all right i'm back so
Caption: there are a bunch of other models that
Caption: we could go into if we wanted to but i
Caption: won't put you through all of that
Caption: but i made a list of just a few of them
Caption: so we had a look at ryb rgbh we did not
Caption: look at hsl we looked at cmycmyk and hex
Caption: but there are a bunch of others these
Caption: are just some ones that i randomly
Caption: googled some of them are in css some of
Caption: them are applied elsewhere um so for
Caption: example cmy cmyk that's used in printing
Caption: so if you think um
Caption: do you want to have a printer anymore
Caption: but if you think to the days of a
Caption: printer
Caption: and you had like
Caption: the cyan magenta magenta and yellow
Caption: cartridge and then a black one that
Caption: comes from cmyk the k being black or the
Caption: key color
Caption: and the reason that you had to add black
Caption: separately i always thought it was just
Caption: because you use more black ink that was
Caption: not the case it's because you can't make
Caption: black with c and y the closest you can
Caption: get is like a really muddy brown
Caption: so i thought that was interesting
Caption: and also the reason it's called k they
Caption: say it's because key color but actually
Caption: b was taken by blue so they had to give
Caption: it a different name
Caption: okay
Caption: so
Caption: why
Caption: why did i put you through a good 50
Caption: minutes now on a talk about color why
Caption: did i bring paint in why did i bring
Caption: torches and why did i put you through
Caption: this
Caption: so firstly i'd like to remind you that
Caption: you picked this room i'm really sorry to
Caption: you
Caption: um
Caption: this started so the reason that i wanted
Caption: to give this talk is it started when i
Caption: saw a front-end developer tweet oh my
Caption: gosh this is how hex codes work and they
Caption: had this big tweet thread about this
Caption: discovery they'd made when they suddenly
Caption: learned how these things worked and i
Caption: was reading this tweet like wait people
Caption: don't know this like this isn't just
Caption: common knowledge and i'm like no people
Caption: have hobbies people don't spend their
Caption: weekends googling how x codes work and
Caption: binary and about light waves and retinas
Caption: that's just me
Caption: so i thought that if that front-end
Caption: developer found this interesting maybe
Caption: other developers would find this
Caption: interesting as well and again i feel
Caption: validated because the number of people
Caption: in this room slowly increased as i was
Caption: talking so i'm feeling pretty good right
Caption: now so that was one reason i just
Caption: thought it was interesting maybe
Caption: somebody else would be interested in
Caption: this as well
Caption: but more than that um i like to when i'm
Caption: teaching because i i teach people how to
Caption: code all the time and i try to put in
Caption: perspective hey it's not actually just
Caption: about the computer like and the way the
Caption: computer works it's not a coincidence so
Caption: we use these things a lot so us we're at
Caption: a developer conference like we live on
Caption: computers but so does everybody else
Caption: like these things like really influence
Caption: something like ingrained in our everyday
Caption: lives now and so i think it's kind of
Caption: important that we have some
Caption: understanding of how these things work
Caption: so like
Caption: to me it's just a middle box but to
Caption: other people they're just magical and
Caption: it's so fascinating it's this
Caption: all-knowing thing and oh no what if i
Caption: mess up what if i do something wrong but
Caption: it's just a metal box it was created by
Caption: humans
Caption: for humans to make our lives easier and
Caption: how it works is pretty cool but it's
Caption: definitely not magic and the stuff
Caption: doesn't have to be so inaccessible so
Caption: whenever you're writing some code you're
Caption: like man i wonder how that hex code
Caption: works like this is something that you
Caption: could google and figure out if you
Caption: wanted to um
Caption: it's not actually as complicated as a
Caption: lot of people might think it is so
Caption: basically i just think that computers
Caption: don't need to be such a mystery um and i
Caption: find the stuff really interesting and i
Caption: really hope
Caption: that you found it interesting as well
Caption: and i hope that when you next go to
Caption: write a hix or an rgb code in your css
Caption: you're going to smile and pause and be
Caption: like hey i know how that works
Caption: so thank you so much to listening to me
Caption: today
Caption: check me and follow on twitter if you
Caption: want to talk about colors or dogs or
Caption: coding fails
Caption: and feel free to check out my blog for a
Caption: summary of this talk thank you
Caption: [Applause]